how much of these investments and the
building of the companies is dependant
just on who's driving the company versus
picking the right markets or you know
actually building the right products
like you've invested in so many
companies at this point you know there's
the argument that some people are
founder investors some are market and
some are product like where do you come
out on that framework and what do you
actually look for when you're making
these investments yeah I was telling the
story of my daughter when she was 11 I
took her to her favorite sushi place and
she was like that how do you how do you
invest you know what do you what do you
do and and I looked her and I said you
know I call it the love principle like
you have to love the founder the team
the product the market right and if you
don't love any one of those things
probably not a good investment and she
looks up at me and she was like well I
love Great America and I was true she
would go there every weekend we'd always
go for Hollywood Halloween Haunt and and
and I was like okay so you love Great
America like here's what you have to do
you have to go there and interview and
do what's called diligence interview the
employees get it you know get get
insights and she did that she being back
she's like dad all the employees like
love the company they love the CEO the
company's called Cedar Fair the 49ers
are doing a billion dollar stadium there
and I was like there you go so Cedar
Fair is a public company that's your
first investment so she made a hundred
percent return and she's starting her
own company now 19 and when she was 18
she started and you know she learned a
really important lesson she's using the
profits from that investment that she
did which was 11 to start this company
but I tell that story because that is
exactly how and us like those are the
four quadrants and if I have any kind of
you know qualitative or quantitative
reason not to believe in one of those
things I'm not going to do the
investment and for whatever reason
that's been working I'm up about 73 X
since 2011 which is amazing like I never
first of all I never thought I was going
to
a venture capitalist investor you know
immigrant kid poor kid like I just
didn't I just never I didn't think that
was possible and I was surprised when
that I started getting those you know
offers and and and opportunities and so
that that formula is something you know
that is qualitative and quantitative and
some people are really good at the
quantitative and some people are really
good at the qualitative if your book
good at both I think you can go in the
pantheon of great investors in terms of
track record and also in terms of just
reputation amongst founders I think the
what you said about Elon and Travis is
absolutely right like we look for great
founders right that are building
industries like one of the things I say
is like build industries don't just
build companies and you know that is a
an interesting juxtaposition in terms of
some of the fissures you're seeing in
the venture capital world versus you
know founders founders are thinking
amazing founders have a lot of
opportunity to get funding and also can
be picky and choosey and when you're not
picky and choosey you end up with bad
investors on your board on your cap
table and it is a nightmare we've lived
through things like that and it can be
an absolute nightmare and so you know if
you look at like Elon story like they
were venture capitalists that when he
needed the money in December and that 60
minutes interview where he you know had
tears talking about that that that
moment where he thought that his
companies were gonna die right that he
had worked so hard and he put every
dollar that he had into those companies
to save them and he was living at his
friend's homes and didn't have a house
and was basically homeless working on
these companies having put every dollar
that he made on paypal and and and his
other startup there's a mapping company
that he had started in its early 20s and
so he took that kind of bold risk and
you know I think a couple of the VC's
especially one bowed out you know at the
last minute and Elan like had to rescue
the company and and I don't think he
ever forgot that right I don't think he
and he never wanted to be in that
position again where his company could
get killed I think Travis is has gone
through similar types of journeys and
you know he's working on his company I
don't think there is a VC on that cap
table right and so I think what's gonna
happen is great founders like Travis and
others are going to fund other great
founders and founders are going to
become more careful right if they have
the luxury of choice they're going to be
careful about who and what firms and who
what angels what investors they bring in
because if you bring a psychopath into
your company you know if you bring us
you know someone that schemes against
the company for whatever reason it can
kill a company it can destroy billions
of dollars of value and also hold back
progress for Humanity especially with
these types of founders so it's it's an
interesting branch of investing in
entrepreneurship which is there are that
many of these types of founders right
and I have the thesis that as
entrepreneurship spreads and goes viral
that we're gonna find the e lines of
Africa the Travis's of South America
right like we're gonna find the
undiscovered edison's
that are out there that have that talent
but opportunity hasn't come to them
because opportunity wasn't democratized
and that's where we're at now and if you
think about the next 20 years the next
40 years the you know people say
disruption but that doesn't really cover
what's happening the speed at which
these innovations are coming are getting
exponentially faster look at well you
know blockchain and Bitcoin and and
what's happening these are to me
systemic bets long-term systemic bets on
the future of humanity and when you back
someone like Elon or you you know or you
buy and invest in Bitcoin these are two
different types of asset classes but
they're long-term systemic bets on the
future of humanity and I'm into systemic
bets those are those are massive bets
those are those are like Tam's you know
squared you know they're the the what's
a total addressable market of a planet
of a new world of a new civilization
like what right and so if you think that
big and you think intergenerationally if
you think beyond your own life in terms
of your investments whatever you're
investing for your family institution
yourself and so on you have to think
long term